Aus günstigen Zutaten und mit
geschicktem Marketing macht Sebastian Lege
einen teuren High Protein Joghurt.
Der sieht zwar schön aus, für eine gesunde
und eiweißreiche Ernährung braucht man den
aber nicht
Sebastian Lege lässt die Muskeln
spielen. Schließlich gehört Fitness heute
zu einem gesunden Lebensstil dazu.
Trainieren kann man heute an jeder Ecke,
sieben Tage die Woche, 24 Stunden.
Die Lebensmittelindustrie hat dafür auch
die passenden Produkte entwickelt, mit
ganz viel Eiweiß. Die Muskeln sollen
ja wachsen. Eiweiß ist in vielen
Lebensmitteln enthalten und gilt als der
Baustoff des Körpers. Milchprodukte wie
Quark oder Frischkäse enthalten von
Natur aus besonders viel davon.
Doch immer mehr Molkereien bieten
inzwischen neue Produkte an, mit
auffälliger Werbung für Protein - nur ein
anderes Wort für Eiweiß.
Auffällig ist auch ihr Preis. Im
Vergleich zu herkömmlichen
Milchprodukten sind die Extra-Protein
Varianten im Schnitt deutlich teurer.
Doch enthalten die Proteinprodukte
wirklich so viel mehr Eiweiß, dass es sich
für die Kunden lohnt?
Sebastian Lege weiß: Für die Industrie
geht die Rechnung auf jeden Fall auf.
Warum? Das zeigt Lege, in dem er selbst
eine Protein-Quark-Creme kreiert.
Da lacht die Kalkulation.
Mit viel Wasser rührt der Produktentwickler eine
Basis aus Milchpulver, Stärke und
Milchsäure-Kulturen an. Diese Zutaten
stecken auch in fast allen Protein-
Erzeugnissen der Industrie und sind
ziemlich günstig.
Riecht relativ neutral.
Neben Geschmack fehlt auch noch die
nötige Portion Proteine. Denn werben darf
man damit nur, wenn das Eiweiß mindestens
20 Prozent des Gesamtmehrwertes liefert.
Magerquark löst das Problem, er enthält von Natur aus viel Protein.
Nun gründlich mixen.
Fertig ist mein Protein-Snack.
Gemacht aus billigsten Zutaten. Sebastians Wareneinsatz pro 150
Gramm Becher - gerade einmal 18 Cent und
die 9,3 Prozent Eiweiß tragen genug zum
Nährwert bei, um als proteinreich zu
gelten.
Eine ähnliche Menge steckt deshalb auch
in den Protein Produkten der Industrie.
Auch wenn das auf den ersten Blick nach
viel aussieht -  im Vergleich zu
herkömmlichen Milchprodukten ist der
Proteingehalt nicht höher.
Quark, körniger Frischkäse oder
Naturjoghurts enthalten sogar oft mehr
Protein, kosten aber weit weniger. Dass
sich die überteuerten Protein-Kreationen
trotzdem verkaufen, das liegt auch an
einem anderen Trick - der Verpackung.
Marketing ist alles. Wie es funktioniert
zeigt Sebastian anhand seiner eigenen
Kreation. Die schwarze Farbe sorgt für
den Look eines Fitnessproduktes für Sportler.
Der Begriff "High Protein" klingt nach
einem wahren Nährstoff-Kick. Außerdem
druckt Lege die Proteinmenge des
gesamten Bechers auf, so sieht es nach
besonders viel aus.
In einem Fitnessstudio in Düsseldorf
macht Sebastian den Test. Was kommt
besser an - seine Eigenkreation in
dynamischen Design oder der klassische
Magerquark? Dessen Verpackung ist eher
schlicht und unauffällig - der
Eiweißgehalt jedoch liegt über dem des
Proteinprodukts.
Fallen die Tester auf den Trick herein?
Wenn die im Kühlregal stehen würden, zu
welchem Produkt würdest du greifen?
Schwarz. Ja? Ja. Zack, du greifst jetzt zu einem, ganz emotional gesehen.
Ganz emotional würde ich dieses hier nehmen
Zum Schwarzen.
Wahrscheinlich der Schwarze. Ich würde
zu dem greifen. Von den dreien die goldene
Mitte. Den Speisequark? Ja. Bis auf einen
einzigen Tester greifen alle zum Protein-
Design-Produkt. Warum?
Das sieht stylisch aus, das Schwarze, auf jeden Fall. Ok, hat so bisschen einen trendigen Touch.
Ich weiß nicht, es hat vielleicht ein bisschen bessere Nährwerte.
Weil ich gedacht habe, da sind viele Proteine und viel Eiweiß drin.
Sebastians Test zeigt, Nährstoff Annonce und schicke
Verpackung - das zieht. Die Proteinmasche zielt vor allem auf Ernährungsbewusste.
Eine gesunde, proteinreiche
Nährstoffversorgung liefern aber genauso
klassische Milchprodukte und man spart
dabei auch noch eine Menge Geld.
Die Industrie wendet den Protein-Trick
längst nicht nur bei Milchprodukten an.
Auch andere Lebensmittel werden mit
Protein beworben.
Knusper, Knabber oder Süßkram -  kaum etwas
bleibt von diesem Trend verschont.
Aber mal ehrlich - sind extra Proteine
überhaupt nötig und nützlich?
Für die Allgemeinbevölkerung sind besonders
proteinreiche Produkte nicht notwendig.
Üblicherweise braucht ein Erwachsener
0,5 bis 0,8 Gramm Eiweiß pro Kilogramm
Körpergewicht pro Tag - heißt also ein
Mensch, der 70 Kilo wiegt sollte zwischen
35 und 50 Gramm Eiweiß pro Tag zu sich
nehmen.
Das zu schaffen ist kein Kunststück, wie
unser Beispiel zeigt. Ein Glas Milch, eine
Schale Haferflocken, eine Portion Nüsse,
eine Scheibe Hähnchenbrust und zwei
Scheiben Käse reichen aus. Extra
Proteinprodukte sind also nicht nur
teuer, sondern auch überflüssig.
Viele Proteine, wenig Fett - worauf achtet ihr
bei eurer Ernährung? Sagt es uns in den
Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer Essen
wissen wollt, dann abonniert die ZDF
besseresser und schaut in den nächsten
zwei Clips.